this is really an honor to be here thank
you for having me I heard that this is
the last lecture series of the semester
and I know you guys are like going into
finals I definitely remember what that
feels like so I really appreciate you
guys taking the time and coming out and
I'd love to answer some questions at the
end so please like I keep that keep
those coming like keep thinking about
them as I'm presenting for those of you
that don't know about ModCloth I saw
that there may be a few hands that
didn't go up we're an online retailer of
women's fashion and decor we carry
independently designed items and we
design our own lines in-house we have
about 7,500 items on the site these are
from designers based around the world
and you know I think that our customers
would tell you that we have some of the
coolest product that you can't find
anywhere else but I think they would
also say that we are more than cool
product we've really built a name for
ourselves in putting our community at
the center of everything that we do
which is pretty innovative for a fashion
retailer like traditionally fashion is
very tops down it's sort of like we tell
you what's cool and then you buy it and
you wear it and then we tell you what's
cool you know next week and then you buy
it anywhere and it's like constantly
this cycle it's been like this very like
a lot of businesses have been
interrupted by you know the technology
changes have happened in the last 10-15
years very tops down very hierarchical
and we've sort of flipped that pyramid
like we've said that we want to put our
community at the center of everything we
do we want to empower her to help us
pick the products that we sell on our
site she actually helps us design some
of the products that we sell on our site
she helps us merchandise them by taking
outfit photos she leaves really detailed
reviews to help other community members
find the right fit and enhance their
shopping experience and you know I could
like describe our customer to you and
you know like in demographics and
psychographics like she's in her 20s and
30s like our Adrienne just kind of 18 to
35 but it goes well
that and it goes above as well the
average age of our customer is 27 but I
think that a picture is worth a thousand
words right so like this is her this is
our community like this is kind of the
best way to get a sense of what our
brand is and what ModCloth is to give
you a sense of our scale quickly today
we now have a team of over 350 we're
based in three offices across the
country our headquarters are here in San
Francisco which is where I live
Pittsburgh has our fulfillment and
distribution we do all of our product
photography there as well I'm a Carnegie
Mellon alums they'll talk more about
Pittsburgh a little bit later in the
presentation why Pittsburgh as a city
specifically is on this list here and
our buying office is in Los Angeles and
our in-house design team is there as
well so I spend a lot of time with our
team in LA developing and designing the
products and picking the products from
the market that we sell to our customers
another way to get a sense of our scale
like these are some of our followers on
social networks like we're one of the
highest followed retailers on Pinterest
I think that probably makes a lot of
sense when you think about our community
that I just showed you like it's it's a
pretty good fit there you know other
than these numbers right like I'd say no
we shipped close to 2 million orders
last year like it's it's definitely come
a long way from you know when I started
at 17 in my parents living room and I
won't spend a ton of time on this but I
wanted to just kind of run run through
our founding story and like how ModCloth
came to be you know honestly like I
don't know that I was a born
entrepreneur like I've I wasn't that
girl that was like selling lemonade you
know as soon as I could and like trying
to employ my friends like it make an
extra buck but I'm absolutely an
entrepreneur through and through that's
one thing that I would like love to
share with you guys like if you could
take something away from this like there
is no right way to be an entrepreneur he
knows I've gone through this journey and
as
had the incredible opportunity to meet
so many other amazing entrepreneurs like
yes there are those born entrepreneurs
who when you hear their stories you're
like oh my god like basically as soon as
you could talk you were trying to sell
something and to start a business and
that's amazing and I really respect that
but you can come to entrepreneurism you
couldn't find your entrepreneurial path
in many different ways and I think that
I'm proof of that so for me it starts
with my passion for fashion and just
loving clothes and I'm not ashamed to
admit it might sound on intellectual but
I've always liked getting dressed and
it's always something that I was drawn
to and I was passionate about and I had
an eye for I didn't have a ton of
disposable income growing up so I
started shopping at thrift stores and
vintage stores like basically I wanted
to be able to stand out and I wanted to
be able to buy things that other people
wouldn't have and you know the
intersection of those two things like a
little bit of disposable income and
wanting to stand out led me to vintage
and thrift store shopping I grew up in
South Florida in a suburb near Fort
Lauderdale and you know I was a Florida
girl like I had seen snow once and when
I was in high school like I worked
really hard I wanted to not be a Florida
girl anymore I got into Carnegie Mellon
and I decide to be a business major cuz
you know I slay didn't really know
exactly what I wanted to do but I
figured like business maybe could lead
to fashion I I honestly didn't really
know what jobs existed in the fashion
industry other than this concept of
being a fashion designer and I wasn't
sure that I had the artistic skills to
be a fashion designer
so I got into Carnegie Mellon I had to
move up to Pittsburgh and experience my
first winter ever which is kind of
daunting and maybe you guys had an
opposite experience coming to beautiful
sunny Stanford from a place that was
cold and snowy but you know for me like
I couldn't I had to buy a whole new
wardrobe and I couldn't do that in South
Florida you know even if I had the
disposable income to be able to go to
the mall
by everything brand-new there isn't
winter wear or even like autumn wear in
the malls in South Florida in the
summertime and so I started going to
thrift stores and looking for winter
wear for the first time and I found a
lot of amazing stuff and like I think
that was kind of the moment when I sort
of started to become an entrepreneur
like that like seed started to grow like
I was just like I can't pass up these
beautiful pieces of clothing I know
they're worth so much more than they you
know kind of marked at just sitting here
like maybe this was like my innate
merchants coming out and I just I found
myself buying stuff even if it didn't
fit me and I would kind of say like oh
like I'll give it to a friend or I will
use the buttons for a craft project
which would never happen or I'll learn
to sew and I'll tailor it to fit me
which also has not happened I still
don't know how to sew
that's okay but I was I was bringing all
this stuff home like trash bags trash
bags full of it and I started dating
this guy around the same time he was his
Mike his name's Eric he's my husband
today is my co-founder at ModCloth and
he had actually started a web hosting
business with two of his friends in high
school I would say he is more of that
born entrepreneur like thinking about
running a business from you know age 4
or whatever like as soon as he could
talk and kind of think about what he
wanted to do so he had this web hosting
business he'd built a few e-commerce
sites like think about it this is like
2000 2001 it was sort of like were these
like young smart kids like let's help
you get on the interwebs like it would
go around to local business owners in
the South Florida area and kind of pitch
them on like we'll help you get you need
a web site to like make your small
business bigger and so he had some
experience and he was actually the one
that suggested that I build a website
and sell some of these products that I
was finding this like one of a kind he's
one of the kind of touch pieces and I
thought that it sounded like a fun
challenge
I mean quite honestly I also thought hey
if I sell some of this stuff that means
that I get to buy more
stuff which sounds really cool and it's
you know again like thinking back to
that time right like there weren't
really any other options like eBay was
an option but I wasn't really finding
designer goods and I didn't really think
I could like build a brand on eBay it
seems like I if I was going to do it I
wanted to be able to control the kind of
more of the customer experience more of
the shopping experience and you know
there wasn't at sea there wasn't you
know any of these like easy to start up
shopping carts there was no Instagram to
sell on like when I think about the
entrepreneurs are starting today it's
like all you really need is a mobile
phone and an Instagram account and you
can be connected to you know you can be
a tastemaker to a group of people that
kind of look up to you and think that
you have good taste it was it was
different than which is kind of crazy I
mean I still consider myself like very
young and I'm still like learning and
kind of exploring the world but then
when I think back to when I started my
business like there was no iPhone there
was no Facebook like it's hard to
imagine and so I I was gifted a digital
camera for my high school graduation
gift it was my first digital camera I
was like kind of like a brick and I used
that digital camera and I used you know
this all these kind of leftovers that I
was finding when I was thrifting to
launch the website I also taught myself
Photoshop I taught myself some web
design I think I was using like God like
Microsoft front-page it's like something
kind of embarrassing and my boyfriend
helped me like hack an open-source
shopping cart we used interchange which
was like a Linux shopping cart if anyone
ever saw that floating around back in
the day and I spent that summer before I
moved up to Pittsburgh kind of like we
incorporated and I bought the first set
of inventory and I merchandised that
inventory like I wrote all the
descriptions I thought the names I
designed the site I thought about like
some of the user experience of the site
you know as much as we could kind of
change from this open source platform
and we launched in January of 2003 and
we act
had a sale on our very first day it was
not someone I was related to or someone
that I knew which was very exciting it
kind of felt like magic and I think like
that was so if like going into the surf
stores and seeing those products and
seeing opportunity was the seed like
that was like the moment when I like I
feel like I became an entrepreneur like
I was just like wow this is really cool
like I can go out and find this stuff
and I can like do all these things that
I really like to do and like people will
pay me for it like that's pretty awesome
and if I could like I was like just
getting started in my college career and
I was just thinking about you know the
things what I wanted to be as an adult
the things I wanted to study and the
things I wanted to do and I kind of had
this like inkling of like wow if I could
do my own thing like that would be
pretty special that would be pretty
amazing
so I ran the business part-time while I
was at school I continued to sell
one-of-a-kind vintage and you know it it
grew it was like kind of fits and starts
you know like some months it was really
slow we'd only have a handful of orders
I was doing whatever I could I ended up
being a double major I double majored in
business and in German so I had like a
pretty rigorous course load as well but
like on spring break
winter break summers like whenever I
could whenever I wasn't like you know
doing other stuff that normal college
kids do like I just kept coming back to
this like I I loved it and I was getting
better at it and that was a really good
feeling and so when I was approaching
graduation in 2006 I you know kind of my
junior my senior year I really started
thinking about ModCloth as a legitimate
career option and it was a scary
decision to have to make and one of the
things that I intuitively did that I
would recommend to all of you guys and
it's like been something that's been
really powerful in my life is like when
you're making big decisions like this
and maybe it's obvious and you guys
already do this but you're making if
you're making big decisions like sit
down and really think about like what
are the worst-case scenarios and write
them down and like get them out there
and you know you won't get them 100%
right but like get comfortable with
those
and then you know then you can go ahead
and make your decision that's always
helped me and this was definitely what I
was doing at this time in my life
and I was thinking about like wow if
this doesn't work like I'm gonna be
behind my peers like I haven't gotten
you know I was like kind of making these
decisions of like do I spend the summer
working on the business or do I try to
get an internship like where do I devote
my time that's like the eternal question
for I mean everyone but particularly for
entrepreneurs where do I devote my time
that question will never go away but I
you know I I really i sat down I said
okay like I don't I don't get a job like
maybe you know people look at me and say
like wow like what was she doing she
didn't get a job right out of college
like it's all these things maybe I won't
be able to pay my student loans
worst case scenario like maybe I will go
bankrupt I'm young I don't have a family
that's okay
you know like I like put that all out
there and really thought about it and
you know it's it's scary but at least
like you know what you're scared of
versus just like being afraid of like
the unknown so in 2000 in 2005-2006
you know I spent a lot of time thinking
about the business model like I knew if
I wanted to I knew that we had a lot of
traffic I knew that like new things that
were happening on the web like Facebook
you know like as a student at the time
so one of the first people to use it you
know I saw the power of not just
building an online retailer but really
building a community and allowing like I
I realized that part of why customers
were drawn to ModCloth was not just the
fashion but it was because they were
similarly minded individuals some really
similarly minded women and I saw this
opportunity to build a community to
build a lifestyle to build something
that was more than just about fashion
and that spoke to the spoke to customers
and that empowered them to be actually
part of the process right like Facebook
isn't fun if your friends aren't on it
in the same way like I thought that I
could build a retailer that would
actually allow you to meet new people
meet new like-minded people get style
inspiration get style advice from not
just like a fashion company but from
other individuals there's also the rise
of personal bloggers and celebrity
bloggers and kind of like everyone was
gaining an audience and I saw this
opportunity to build my brand and to
gain an audience from ModCloth
and so as I was thinking a lot about the
business model I was thinking about all
this stuff that was happening at the
time and it saw the opportunity to you
know not I knew that I had to move away
from one-of-a-kind vintage pieces like
it's not scalable it's not a great
customer experience either you know
everything is like in one color and in
one size but I really had no idea where
to start
like I wasn't a fashion person I was
based in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania not
necessarily the most fashionable city in
the world at Carnegie Mellon which isn't
really a school that has you know a lot
of people like I was starting to meet
entrepreneurial mentors but I didn't
really have anyone that in my life that
had retail experience at that time but I
was eventually able to find to find
independent designers and to really make
the business start to look like what it
looks like today which is you know this
mix of products that you know some of
them have a direct vintage inspiration
but really like all fashion is vintage
inspired in some way or another cuz it's
like whether it's a dress from the 40s
that then was reinterpreted in the 80s
then is reinterpreted today and it's
just you know hemlines are longer
shorter shoulder pads get bigger and
tinier and kind of moved to different
spots the silhouette changes but it's
all inspired in some way so I I I was
able to kind of take this this business
started in you know in my parents living
room and eventually moved into this was
this photo here in 2006 was our first
like official fulfillment center and
then looking at today like we're in a
200,000 square foot fulfillment center
in Pittsburgh you know like I said we're
shipping two million orders last year
you know it's we've come a long way
but another lesson that I've learned as
an entrepreneur is that you know part of
that drive will like the cut that really
drives you to start things will never
let you be satisfied so it's really
important as an entrepreneur I think to
like work to work on the practice of
like celebrating your wins and like
taking a moment to step back and saying
like wow we've actually come a long way
because I look at this and I'm like okay
we've come a long way but we still have
I still have such high aspirations for
the brand I have such high aspirations
for the business we still have such a
long way to go
and that's been like an important
learning for me is like how do you how
do you make it sustainable how do you
like celebrate these wins but still keep
that drive to want to get bigger and
better so I'm still excited to get
bigger and better I'm still learning
tons of lessons along the way and one of
the biggest ones that I've learned thus
far is that you know it's okay to be you
know I'm kind of calling it like it's
okay to be a rookie like it's okay to
kind of not know what you're doing it's
okay to come at problems from a really
kind of like rookie mentality and that
can actually be it's not just okay but
it can actually really be an advantage
and I think that you know as I look back
at my career and like my story at
ModCloth I think that it absolutely was
an advantage for us in a lot of ways
like I said like we weren't retail
veterans like we didn't come from retail
families like this is a photo of me with
our first delivery of you know non
vintage merchandise like peeking over
those boxes like oh my god what am I
gonna do with all these boxes next this
is like literally you can kind of tell
literally in our college house and you
know like when I was going through this
process like back in this like really
formative time like 2005-2006 and
thinking about making this real business
like I literally had to Google like
where do I find wholesale clothing like
I didn't I didn't know where to go
who to ask and you know it eventually
like all my googling eventually led me
to like some of the major fashion trade
shows and I kind of like bought a ticket
to Las Vegas and went to these trade
shows and like walked in without knowing
what to expect and you know like I
thought maybe it's gonna be this like
glamorous thing I mean you hear about a
fashion trade show it sounds like maybe
it's gonna be kind of cool in reality
this is what it actually looks like
you're in the Las Vegas Convention
Center you're walking through you know
it's kind of concrete there's no windows
so this was what I walked into you know
with this kind of rookie mentality and I
think the fact that I did just go in and
like asked a ton of questions and was
like you know like I literally asked
about everything I mean I probably
honestly was like asking some dumb
questions like I was like if I buy this
how many do I have to buy and when will
you shift it to me and when will I pay
you and like some of these things that
you know usually you know by the time
you get to this level and you know what
I learned about the trade shows like
really quickly right is like the buyers
go there they walk the floor like
everyone from you know small retailers
like ModCloth was at the time to like
the big department stores they walk the
floor they look at the designers the
designers all bring samples that they're
hoping to put into production they see
how many buyers are interested in the
samples and then they go back and they
make some bets and they say okay this is
you know we have some pre-orders for
these and like these things people were
kind of interested in so this is where
we're gonna you know kind of place our
bets and like place our production
orders and so what I realized really
quickly in 2006-2007 is I was starting
to like build out our desire portfolio
and move away from this one-of-a-kind
vintage model was that a lot of the
items that I really loved weren't
getting made and so what I'd hear from
the designers is like oh but Nordstrom
bought this one don't you want this one
this one will get made and of course I
didn't want the item that Nordstrom
bought even if it was a great seller for
Nordstrom because I needed
differentiated cool product for my
customer so you know I kind of like I
asked some rookie questions like I was
like hold on you guys have all of these
samples here and you're showing them to
like just because I'm the only one that
likes them like sometimes half of the
items that we were finding at these
trade shows weren't getting made like we
had a really big fallout rate so yeah I
asked some of these questions you know I
said we have all these samples here like
I have all these customers that I can
talk to like immediately I don't have to
you know wait six months and then walk
out onto a sales floor like the
traditional brick-and-mortar guys do
why can't if you have these samples here
you've already gone through the cost of
making the sample can I just take those
samples and see maybe my customers will
really love it maybe I can help you get
to that you know usually depending on
the item it's like a hundred to six
hundred minimum production order so
maybe I can help you get to that so I
can it I can like guarantee my order and
I can give you some real customer
feedback this led to our be the buyer
program which we launched in 2009 this
is kind of like a quick snapshot of the
concept but it really came from this
like rookie mentality of like why not
why can't we do this and I think like
some people in the fashion industry kind
of had this reaction of like but that's
your job as a buyer like that's the
thing that you're supposed to do is
you're supposed to go out there and like
kind of you know make your educated
guess of what the customer will like but
from my perspective I was like I don't
have to take that risk and I can
actually engage my customers and let her
let them let her be part of the process
like wouldn't that be much better for
everyone
for indepent is iers as well like this
was giving them direct customer feedback
rather than just getting traditionally
they just heard from the buyers whether
why the buyers like something or not so
giving them this like actual feedback
from customers was a really innovative
thing at the time and this was a really
important part of our growth like we
were able to for one like get more items
that we actually needed like I said like
half of the items were falling out it's
time and this was like the core of you
know this like launched the core of
our core tenant at our company that the
we should really be empowering the
community to help us make these
decisions even these decisions that
traditionally are made internally at
traditional fashion retailers I think
that it's important so telling this
whole story like I think it's also
important as entrepreneurs to have keep
in mind that fake it till you make it is
totally valid like that concept but it's
just one of many tools in your toolbox
and that's something that I've found as
I've looked back in my career and you
know as I think about what I would share
with my younger self I think that often
we try to like just fake until we make
it all the time and I think part of it
is kind of the culture like especially
in the entrepreneurial world like you're
just you're always you know you're just
like yes of course I can do this of
course we'll be able to hit these
numbers of course we'll be able to you
know we know what our plans are going to
be one year from now two years from now
five years from now and you know that's
totally fine and like sometimes you
really do have to do that like when
you're when you're pitching your
business when you're shocking to
investors like absolutely fake it till
you make it but I think that sometimes
like if you get too caught up in this
mentality like you can I I would caution
you to resist like faking it because you
might miss opportunities to actually
find your own path and you might miss
these opportunities to kind of put your
hand up and say like why are we doing it
this way why is it happening this way
does this actually make sense and this
has been a really valuable lesson for me
okay one last word on being a rookie I
Hotel everyone out here you know don't
be afraid to go into an industry that
you don't know anything about I'll say
like look at this girl if she can go on
to be the creatively
of a you know well-loved
multimillion-dollar fashion brand like
you can do it too
even you know even if you're not raised
in it it's not like in your blood or
whatever I think that I am living proof
that if you're passionate about
something like you can create your own
kind of your own place in that world
okay so this leads very well to my next
lesson which is that it's okay to look
back and cringe I'm definitely putting
those pictures up makes me cringe a
little bit not gonna lie I think this
has been a really important lesson for
me as a creative entrepreneur I think
especially as you start and you're out
in your career it can be really scary to
be vulnerable and to put your work out
in the world you want everything to be a
hundred percent perfect and I don't
think this is just you know when I say
creative I mean like I'm definitely I
spend a lot of my job and a lot of my
time thinking about aesthetics and
thinking about you know design and these
sorts of things but I think this is just
as applicable to you know if you're a
coder or whatever you're doing whatever
type of product you're building like
when you're starting out your career you
are not going to be good and you are
hopefully gonna get better which means
that you're gonna look back and your
tastes are gonna be better and you're
gonna know so much more and you're gonna
cringe on your earlier work so you have
to just like get out there and do stuff
this is one of my favorite quotes by the
author Neil Gaiman like if you're making
mistakes means you're out there doing
something and I think it can be hard
sometimes right like you want to just
like you want to wait until it's
absolutely perfect and I'm not
advocating by any means that you should
you know not care very much about what
you do and not have like real attention
to detail but I think that this like
having this permission of like no no
matter what I'm gonna get better and I'm
gonna look back and cringe on my earlier
work I think it's really freeing so it's
something that you know it's it's one of
those lessons that's like easy to listen
to and maybe to understand
intellectually and it's harder
to actually put work in your life as an
entrepreneur and still trying to work on
and it can be tough quite honestly to
find that balance of like having that
attention to detail and not wanting to
release a thing until it's perfect
and just getting it out there and like
knowing that it's gonna change and
you're gonna move on and you're gonna
look back and you're gonna cringe one
way or the other so let's just take a
moment I will show you my look back and
cringe this is the first version of
ModCloth this is our first logo I think
it's very clearly designed by a 17-year
old who's just learned Photoshop yeah
you know but this doesn't mean that like
like I was really proud of this thing
when we released it you know I spent
time on it and I was thoughtful and you
know I thought that this like embodied
my brand and I thought that bevel looked
really cool but I look back on it now
and it's it's cringe-worthy this is the
next version of the site this was
2005-2006 we'd switched to a new another
like open-source like Linux based
shopping cart but again it was like I
had taken a few design classes it was
like starting to get a little better but
like this is some of the content that we
were producing around that time I look
back at it and I'm like oh my god oh
it's horrible but I if I hadn't done it
if I hadn't put it out there it wouldn't
be where I am today this is kind of
circa 2007 2008 starting to come along
you're starting to see some of the like
kind of more of the hallmarks of the
ModCloth brand that you see today for
those of you that are familiar with the
brand and you're starting to see more of
like our kind of playful quirkiest that
I come through but you know again I look
back at this you know in the work that I
do today and I'm like thanks you know
and like I said it is it is about having
this you know this is where we're at
today and it's having this permission to
to be okay with the fact that you know
in 10 years you'll look back and like
you'll be proud of what you did but
hopefully you're gonna be better and
you're gonna be past that stage in your
career in your life and you're gonna be
you know on to greater and better things
so the way that we think about like this
philosophy and like putting it into
practice today at ModCloth is you know
in one way like thinking about the
concept in our product development on
the technology side of a Minimum Viable
Product and you know I'm sure you guys
are probably familiar with this type of
concept you know it's like think about
what's the minimum that I need to put
this on to the world and get user
feedback on it so an example like a more
recent example for us at ModCloth is our
style gallery like this is a feature
that we built and we launched on our
site in 2012 and like the two goals are
you know let our customer come and
upload a photos and like browses outfit
photos and get inspired and love them
and kind of you know build the community
in that way and then the second goal was
to make this a fit photos shoppable and
this was the first version that we
rolled out you know we worked really
hard on it we felt really good about it
but you know as soon as we got it out
there to our users we solve it she knew
she realized that she should browse and
she got the inspiration part of it but
she did not get the shopping part at all
you know so we iterated like released
many new versions like lots of small
iterations we found that just like
adding this magnifying glass on the
mouse over told her that she could
actually click in and shop so it's like
these little things and you know even
though the first version of our style
gallery failed right like we wanted it
to do two things and it only did one of
those things we didn't view it as a
failure like we got something out there
and we learned and you know if we had
waited to like make it a hundred percent
to like like if we weren't diligent on
really thinking about like what is that
Minimum Viable Product yet out there and
to get feedback we would have probably
spent a lot of time like running in a
different direction
because once you actually get things in
front of your community
in front of your users like that's where
you get the feedback that actually
matters and you know I think for us and
for our brand like the fact that our
customers were able to you know be part
of this experience of iterating like she
tells us what she likes and what she
doesn't then she actually sees that we
listen and that we make changes that's
really empowering to our customers and
that's like that empowerment is more
than just retail it's more than just
transaction like that is part of the I
think emotional core of what has made
ModCloth successful and I think what's
made ModCloth like loved by our
community as a brand and that's the kind
of final thing that I really want to
talk about today is that the emotional
core of what you do like the purpose of
what you do as an entrepreneur is really
important and that's really what endures
I think part of this is you know it's
not just external it's not just that the
emotional core of what you do connects
your customers to you but it's internal
as well like your purpose is what
connects your team to the work it's what
makes you know employees like an actual
team an actual company it makes it's
what makes everyone move in the same
direction and I think that you know
ModCloth like our purpose is really
defined on understanding our audience
like we know that you know if you ask
women this study showed that 96% of
women say that what that they say that
they agree with the statement that what
you wear affects how you feel right and
that's more than dresses like it's more
than just a transaction and like being
able to connect to that I think has been
like externally and internally has been
well most one of the most valuable
things that we've done as a company so
understanding so it's important to
understand your audience and I I feel
like there are I when I've talked to
other entrepreneurs about this you know
I hear like
what if I'm in a b2b business I'm not
dealing with an audience like yours that
has this sort of you know emotional need
for product but it's not just about like
I said it's not just about external it's
about internal as well right and I think
like when you think about companies that
are that really endure and the people
love and people love working at it's
having a purpose that's more than just
like we're gonna grow quickly and we're
gonna make money like you need to think
about and I have not come across a
business yet that doesn't have some sort
of emotional core that doesn't make
people's lives better in some way that
doesn't serve some purpose even if you
are b2b like you're helping those other
employees the other employees that those
other businesses be more efficient to
better at their jobs like there is an
emotional core there and I think that
getting to it is really important this
is ours at ModCloth we're committed to
inspiring personal style and helping our
customers feel like the best versions of
themselves and you know it's it's
different from you know I'd say it's
different from the rest of the fashion
industry and that you know we're
encouraging our customers to be
themselves and to be the best versions
of themselves like we're not saying you
have to become this like idealize like
ModCloth version
we're just saying like we'll help you be
the best version of who you are and this
is really powerful like this is what our
this is what our customers see from the
rest of the fashion industry like each
of these images is actually taken from a
different retailers campaign I mean you
see them next to each other and they
they look pretty similar I think and
there's nothing wrong with these images
like they're beautiful and there's I
mean there's like lots of good things to
say about them but for me like I'm a
customer and I look at them
and I don't I don't see myself here like
I don't feel like I belong and this is
an image from one of our most recent
swim campaigns at ModCloth this actually
this campaign went viral it was written
about around the world we decided to
photograph our employees and one of our
best-selling swimsuits it's a swimsuit
that we carry in a broad range of sizes
and that we've carried for years and
years it has like thousands of reviews
from customers of all age ranges and
shapes and sizes let's say that they
love it and this is really powerful I
mean like you look at this and like I
mean I think this is a message in
branding as well like if you are this is
a message this is a lesson in branding
as well right like if you look at these
images even though they're from
different retailers they kind of blend
together this image is different right
and it's important that like your
business aesthetically kind of stands
out as well but emotionally it stands
out too right like this is a different
message this is saying women look
different and that's okay it's something
that can be celebrated and that we can
be happy about and it's also it's like
this is the most vulnerable time for a
woman probably when she's wearing a
swimsuit like that's what we hear from a
lot of our customers and it's saying
like hey you don't it doesn't have to be
that way it's okay
and so I think this this emotional like
I said like this is our emotional core
for our business for all of you like
whether you're starting businesses
you're are an entrepreneur if you're you
know just like you want to take these an
entrepreneurial mindset to a bigger
company like think about the emotional
core of what you do like really is
important it's a lesson that I've you
know I learn all the time like we get
this incredible emotional outpouring
from our customers because they see what
we do for them how we speak to them and
we see it on Facebook we see it on
Twitter we see it internally on our site
and like for me
this is this is the like this is the
thing that I'm most proud of when I talk
about like what I've built in law cloth
and you know I think if you can find
something that you love to do that is
you know financially viable right like
you got to get paid for it
and that also emotionally connects with
other people it makes other people's
lives better in some way that is really
powerful and that's something that's
like worth getting out of bed for and
you know as an entrepreneur like I think
that you have to have I think in some
ways like you have to have that drive
because there's gonna be some days when
you need something to get you out of bed
like it won't be easy
and this emotional core is also what
gets you through tough times right and I
think that you know a lot of times in
the entrepreneurial world like we don't
talk about what it's actually like to go
through tough times like I feel like you
hear a lot of the kind of overnight
success stories and like I've had that
story written about me in various ways
you know like I've been on a lot of
those 25 under 25 and 30 under 30 lists
and you know like entrepreneur does this
great thing and is like built this
credible business and I'll say like at
least from my perspective and like from
the other entrepreneurs that I've met
and I've learned about that concept of
like an overnight success story just
does not exist there's always something
more to it and it's never just like
flowers and rainbows and then I I feel
like on the opposite end of the spectrum
I'm like you do hear about I'll just
pull one out of the sky like you hear
about something like pets calm or it's
like Oh crazy explosion implosion
however you want to describe it but you
don't hear as much about the stuff
in-between like the actual like what is
it like to weather hard times and I've
been through that like the last 12
months at ModCloth were
not the easiest time of my life and part
of why I want to talk about is because I
do think that you don't hear other
entrepreneurs talking about very much
and I do think it's like part of it is
the kind of the culture in the same way
that I was talking about like we feel
like we have to fake it till we make it
that's a tool and it's not something
that you have to do all the time and I
think that yeah often like you know when
you're in the valley or wherever you're
at like you as entrepreneurs you start
to equate like kind of your personal
success and your personal Worth with
your business's success and your
business is worth and I think that that
is there's no way to kind of get around
that when you're starting out because it
is just you and you're you know it's you
and like a very small group of people
and you're putting so much of yourself
into the business but as the business
grows and as you I mean if your goal is
to actually add more people you know it
isn't just you anymore and I think
that's like an important lesson that
founders have to learn is it's not just
going to be you and that's like for the
good times and the bad times like the
good times it's your team the bad times
it's you and your team as well and that
can be again it's one of those lessons
that I think is probably easier to
understand intellectually then to
actually like put in practice in your
life and you know for me over the last
12 months at ModCloth like kind of the
long story short was like we grew really
quickly we had to make some tough
decisions in the business because we
were at a point where we'd grown quickly
we weren't able to support our burn rate
anymore and you know this purpose was
what got me through making those
decisions and like having those times
where it's hard to get out of bed and
it's hard to go to work
that's another thing that's
hard to face as a founder when you know
you've created your own job and you
don't want to go to that job that's a
tough place to be in and I think if you
don't have this purpose if you don't
have something that's deeper that's
pulling you back to it it'll be all but
impossible so you know for us like I
said like we had to make some hard
decisions like we had to lay people off
last year and it was the hardest thing I
have ever done professionally and you
know quite honestly like I felt I spent
a lot of last year kind of personally
feeling like a failure
and that's a tough place to be in and
again like this purpose was what brought
me back to okay even though I'm feeling
this way I can step outside I can look
at this I can look at my business and I
know that my business is a success
because my business has this purpose my
business has this you know this thing
that it's doing like this is real and
we're making a real difference in
people's lives
and having this brought me through that
time it also brought our company through
that time like this was what our team
rallied around and it wasn't easy like I
said like we had to make some hard
decisions to set our business up for
success and said our brand up for the
future and you know we decided to really
focus on the things that we did better
than anyone else in the world that was
thinking about building community and
taking like engaging with that community
and creating products and creating
innovative social experiences that they
would love and that they would respond
to and having that focus and having like
this purpose to kind of drive that focus
enabled us to you know kind of look
forward and start thinking about the
future and as we start thinking about
the future of ModCloth like in the last
like 12 months or so you know we knew
that that involved taking the brand to
the next level
part of that is thinking about what a
physical presence means for ModCloth and
what that would
like and you know whether that's pop-ups
or fit shops or guide shops or some
combination of them brick-and-mortar
stores we knew that was where we wanted
to go we also knew that we needed to
work on our own proprietary products so
thinking about designing things that she
couldn't find anywhere else because we
know our customer best and we know what
will fit her and we have all this like
great data on what works for her so in
order to do that we actually decided to
hire a new CEO someone who had retail
experience and who had kind of done all
of those things had brick a more
experienced understood proprietary
brands and our new CEO started in
January
his name's Matt and you know since
January we've actually already launched
our first fit shop our first fit pop-up
we did this in LA about a month ago and
it was incredible like we had customers
community members lining up around the
block
hundreds of them some of them waiting
for hours to actually get in and be able
to try on our products and interact with
each other and interact with the brands
and you know I've all of this is
possible you know like moving forward
thinking about the future of ModCloth
because of that core and that purpose
and I think like it's part of why I am
so passionate about sharing this message
with other entrepreneurs because I feel
like it's it's easy to think about like
there's just this kind of list of things
that I need to do is an entrepreneur and
I need to just check them off and I need
to go to business I need to do this and
you can do that
and I'm not sure that like this concept
is on that like well-known list this
concept of like find your purpose and
find what you're doing and I'd like it
to be there I also don't think that the
check off the list is like actually a
thing that people should be doing I said
like I feel like all entrepreneurs have
different stories and like come from
different backgrounds and kind of
approach it in different ways but
I do think this is one thing that like
every business or to really like know
where it's going in order to weather
rough times and to be headed in the
right direction in good times like this
is probably like the most important
thing that I would leave you guys with
and I would love to answer some
questions thank you for having me here
today the other people there say so the
question was it's okay to look back and
cringe but sometimes you find that yeah
that the naive version is better for a
certain age group or like for a certain
customer so I I think I see what you
mean and I do think there's definitely
some validity to like I don't think it's
about necessarily like looking back and
saying like that wasn't cutting edge or
that doesn't feel cutting edge because
everything will feel stale you know kind
of a few years into the future so I do
think there's definitely validity to you
know kind of purple like I feel like
maybe what you're asking about is like a
purposeful throwback or something that
feels more I know kind of retro and I
think that's totally valid I do think
though that you know if you so if you
feel good about what you're putting out
into the world like part of the thing
that I want to convey is like if you
feel good about it like get it out there
and don't just kind of sit on it and
hold it in because you want to make it
perfect cuz it'll never be perfect but
yeah I do think that there's there's
validity to looking back and saying like
oh well this is actually great and it's
like perfect again in this moment in
time yes in the back about the
transition you know sort of filling a
simple need like as a small company we
really need consumers and you know that
they want to product and and then being
able to actually empower those consumers
like from Philips fulfilling a simple
need to like being able to empower your
consumers alike contribute to that cycle
yeah so the question is about how what
what was the transition for mod cloths
from going from like a purely
transactional relationship with our
community to actually empowering them to
be part of the process yeah yeah I think
I mean I do think a lot of that for
ModCloth story was timing for us like I
said we were kind of I was like thinking
about taking the business to the next
level at this time where Facebook was
really gaining traction and like all
this stuff on the social web was
happening so for me it like intuitively
made sense that you know whatever
business I was starting like this had to
be a part of it like I looked at the way
you know I was using Facebook in the way
my friends were interacting on Facebook
and it made sense to me that like
because my customers were probably
pretty similar to me and my friends that
they would want to interact in that way
as well and not just with the brand but
with you know kind of each other on the
website and giving them that opportunity
was was gonna be something that would be
not just you know useful for us because
we learn more about them but it would
actually be a brand differentiator and I
think the transition really was you know
around the time that we launched our via
the buyer program
like having that kind of brainstorm of
like oh yeah we could let's ask our
customers let's get them involved let's
listen to them it really was this like
confluence of what we were thinking
about what we were excited about and
what was happening in the market like
and in the broader like social world
that allowed that to happen was that too
vague or does that answer your question
cool I'd like to know do you currently
have your own designers and also I'd
like to know
are you buying and selling globally and
what's been your experience with that
yes so the question was if we have our
own designers which we do so that's
definitely something that you know we
see is a big part of ModCloth future and
moving forward is doing more and more
proprietary design we release about a
hundred and fifty designs a quarter
right now they're coming from our own
internal design team and we see that
scaling quickly the other part of the
question was whether we work with
international designers globally and
kind of what that it goes yeah both
buying and selling so we do sell around
the world our audience is mostly here in
the US but we do have like a fairly
substantial following in Canada and
Australia and like some of the other
english-speaking countries that you'd
expect in like high english-speaking
countries we do work with designers
based around the world and it can be
it's incredible from a branding
perspective being able to introduce a
desire to the US for the first time and
bring them into a new market you know
it's great for their business too and
you know for us like it's part of how we
become known as a place that you know
you can find stuff that you can't get
anywhere else but from a pure like
retail business perspective it can
definitely be a challenge you know it's
hard for designers that haven't worked
with companies in the US before you know
just like all the actual logistics of
like bringing product in and making sure
it's like gonna get through customs I'm
gonna be able to sell in the US
that can be because we work with we
really we really value independent
design so we work with live independence
and some of them are really great at
design and not so good at logistics and
some of the other parts of their
business so we have to kind of step in
and fill that role does that answer your
question yeah the fashion industry it's
really about there is and it's we do
competitive space and I know a lot of
Brandon's people over and out
you see the craziest campaigns but I'm
just curious what is the one thing what
love it differently they've got the
early adaptors yes the question was what
did ModCloth do differently to get early
adopters and I think you know when I
think back to the real early adopters
like people that were joining the brand
in 2006 and 2007 what we did differently
was really go where our customers were
at a time when other fashion brands
weren't thinking about those spaces so
being like one of the first brands to
really build a fan page on Facebook for
this audience going to you know
up-and-coming like celebrity gossip
bloggers and personal style bloggers
because we knew you know we even like we
used to do a lot of advertising we still
do but like we do a lot of advertising
with like cute blogs so like blogs that
post pictures of like bunnies and
kitties and that sort of thing which
isn't fashion related so it wasn't like
entirely clear to the broader industry
that they should go and find customers
there but we knew like I knew because
that's the stuff that I was interested
in and it was new and it was
up-and-coming and like my friends were
interested in it so we were able to go
and like find our customer where she was
at and I think that was definitely what
really spoke to our early adopters they
looked at us and saw us as you know in
some ways like we were early adopters as
well like we were the first to work with
you know have partnerships with certain
fashion bloggers and like be you know
working with them to create great
content that didn't feel like an ad but
you know talked about the brand and like
got brand awareness out
there
you